[Musique]
des plaines arides à perte de vue nous
sommes à Donana l'une des plus grandes
zones humides d'Europe aujourd'hui
presque entièrement sèche
rosée et guide depuis 6 ans plusieurs
fois par semaine il recense les animaux
dans la zone
en temps normal cette zone serait
recouverte d'eau
on pourrait voir ici des flamants roses
différentes espèces de canards des ronds
les oiseaux migrateurs ne s'arrêtent
plus ici
à cause du manque de précipitation en
une année la population d'oiseaux a été
divisée par 5
quand les visiteurs découvrent la
réalité de doniana le plus souvent ils
sont tristes nous aussi je suis triste
mais je suis encore plus préoccupé pour
les générations futures si ça continue
comme ça il ne connaîtront de Nana qu'à
travers les encyclopédies les livres
ces images ont été filmées il y a cinq
ans à l'époque la plus grande lagune de
donyanna était encore un refuge pour de
nombreux animaux même en été
mais cette année l'intense sécheresse a
eu raison de ses dernières gouttes
jouent un rôle crucial car elles ont de
l'eau toute l'année et ceux qui permet à
la faune et la flore de survivre aux
époques arides
mais peut-être que je me trompe
l'agriculture intensive et l'autre
grande raison de cette assèchement 11000
hectares de culture sous serre en tour
dognana un seul hectare nécessite de
piscines olympique d'oparan des milliers
de mètres cubes que certains
agriculteurs puissent illégalement
Juan est activiste ici depuis 30 ans
régulièrement il chasse ses retenues
d'eau illégales
en continu et elle sert à l'irrigation
de tous les champs
il suffit de s'enfoncer quelques mètres
plus loin dans la forêt pour découvrir
des milliers de puis illégaux
ici il y a trois puits regardez tout ce
qu'il y a
une partie de ces terres a été décrétée
en 2014 sous pression de lieu pourtant
ici l'eau coule toujours à flot
ce puits est très grand si on regarde en
contrebas on voit qu'il puisse l'eau à
15 mètres de profondeur c'est à dire au
niveau des nappes phréatiques
le gouvernement soutient certains
agriculteurs qui ne sont pas en règle
ils préfèrent fermer les yeux sur l'état
de doniana pour protéger l'économie
ces dernières années le gouvernement
espagnol a fait fermer 220 puis illégaux
400 autres sont en cours d'examen des
mesures que les écologistes jugent trop
timides
d'autant qu'en parallèle les autorités
andalousent font pression pour leur
régularisation se représentant
d'agriculteurs
régularise les agriculteurs illégaux on
va nous demander d'extraire moins d'eau
et on va devoir réduire notre surface de
culture
ici les fruits rouges sont au cœur d'une
véritable guerre de l’eau car ce
commerce est juteux il représente plus
d'un demi milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires annuel d'après manuel ces
cultures illégales sont un danger pour
l'export
cette image affectent tout le monde
parce que les gens pensent que nous
sommes tous des illégaux alors que nous
cultivons de façon tout à fait légale
depuis 40 ans notre activité dépend du
marché alors si plus personne ne veut
acheter on va devoir arrêter la
production
[Musique]
c'est sous la pression de l'Union
européenne que les régularisations pour
leur été suspendus
manuellement
comment ça va
c'est dans sa petite ville de 40 000
habitants que l'on compte le plus grand
nombre de ses puisses égaux dans cette
salle il archive toutes les infractions
constatées par les autorités espagnoles
comme ces terres sont publiques c'est à
la municipalité de payer en partie ses
amendes
de 160 000 euros c'est tellement
d'argent d'un coup qu'on va devoir
demander des échelonnements de paiement
et ça c'est ce que j'appelle les amendes
habituels de 500 euros
ici une 2000
dans son village qui vit historiquement
de l'agriculture ce maire se dit
abandonné
nous défendons de nyana mais on refuse
que sa protection se fasse à notre
détriment nous avons le droit d'être ici
aujourd'hui on demande aux agriculteurs
de partir tout simplement on leur
propose aucune autre alternative
pour éviter de nouvelles sanctions les
gouvernements centrales et régionales
viennent de présenter à Bruxelles un
plan d'action commun
il propose la fermeture de plus de 1000
puis illégaux mais aussi d'investir plus
de 100 millions d'euros dont des
infrastructures pour améliorer l'état de
l'aquifère peut-être le dernier espoir
de sauver Donya